- [Elevator] Third floor.
- [Woman] Hello professors.
- [Andy] Hey Gary.
- Hey man.
(laughing)
Oh, I'm so sorry
- [Ed] Andy was
just talking a little bit.
I don't know if you can
physically sit
for a little while?
- You mean like reduce
the energy to sit?
- You mean to sit
while he's talking?
- No, stand.
- I'm thrilled to sit.
- No, stand up.
- Okay.
- Alright, so you were
gonna talk a little bit
about something
that was like relative
to the decision
here in yield X.
- I was.
- You remember the call we had?
You don't have to.
- Well just prompt me.
- Prompt you?
- Yeah.
- The go long or sell.
- Right, so being a founder
or being an entrepeneur
is an intensely
personal decision.
- Yeah.
- You're also balancing
lots of different interests.
You're balancing interests
of your investors,
you're balancing interests
of your partners,
of your board of directors,
and your employees.
But ultimately at it's heart,
it's an intensely
personal decision,
and with one of those decisions
only the person can make it.
So you may make the right
one or the wrong one,
but it's intensely
personal at it's core,
and it's really hard for
someone on the outside
to make the investor,
like us, to say
"come on man, go for it."
'Cause we have
diversified portfolios
of investments and businesses,
and in fact if you
think about the concept
of a diversified portfolio,
I say this to
founders all the time,
the success of your
individual business or company
doesn't really affect me.
What affects me is the
diversification of 24 companies
that I invest in over a four
year period out of one fund.
That's all you have,
and I'm constructing a
diversified portfolio
that I know 60 to 70 percent
are probably not going
to return the money,
and 20 to 30 percent
will return my capital,
and one or two will deliver
those outside returns.
So in that balance,
that's not equal,
how can you say to someone,
"you should go for it"?
- So would you back Doug again,
if you had been an investor
and he had taken the term deal?
- Well yes, potentially,
because that's a great set of
experiences.
Most first time entrepreneurs
don't have an experience
to build a company.
Having to raise outside
capital, how to sell it.
Have to balance those,
that could be
good set of experiences.
- So we're talking
about a company
that got a very,
very early offer.
- We talked about it.
- But maybe you can--
Andy gave a little
bit of his background
and his career trajectory
that led him to a fund
that would invest
in his company,
and you have a really
interesting career trajectory,
which maybe you could start--
- I think I should get Gary to
invest in my company either.
- Did you try?
- Of course I tried.
- Why did you--
- I don't recall.
Let me ask you a quick question.
(laughing)
- You don't recall because
it didn't even register?
- No, I wanna get back
to that in a minute.
But there was something
interesting that just happened.
Did you ask him, would he
invest in the person, who,
if he took the term deal,
which is the early deal, right?
- Yeah.
- Well the interesting
part there is
that he would have not
known the other outcome.
- Right.
- Like if they
took that first deal,
they just wouldn't know.
- Right.
- So I think that's something
I'm always fascinated by,
which is people are so
crippled by decisions,
there's just no way to know
what would have happened,
you know, at the time
you're making the decision.
So much of this is Monday
morning quarterbacking.
Fascinating.
So anyway, none the less.
- Let's move over to the middle.
- Yeah.
(laughing)
I've known this man since
I was 14, 15 years old,
because my family
had a liquor store
in Springfield, New Jersey,
that I started working
at when I was 14,
that I later turned into
something called Wine Library,
and launched one of
the first three or four
e-commerce wine
businesses in America,
called WineLibrary.com
back in 1996,
and your professor here
was a hard core wine nerd,
that knew way to much about
wine for such a young dude,
and I was a child,
but that was like my whole
life and what I cared about,
and I built my dad's business
from a three to a 65
million dollar business
with no capital
infusion in '98 to 2003.
- [Ed] Wait, he didn't make a
modest $14 million loan?
- No, no modest
$14 million loan.
(laughing)
But he came to America.
I was born in Belarus with no
language and a hundred bucks
and lived in a studio
apartment in Queens
with eight family members,
so he's very much my hero
to build it up to a three
million dollar level.
But I did it on
digital marketing
innovation of the time.
In 1997 I had an
e-mail newsletter
that had 91 percent open rates,
because nobody
was e-mail marketing,
and instead of sending catalogs
from Sherry-Lehmann's or Zachys,
I was getting to customers
first with the hottest wines
on this thing e-mail.
I was trying to send as many
e-mails as possible in '97,
'cause I thought people would
eventually charge for it.
It seemed such a great deal.
Launching a website, e-mail--
(laughing)
Really!
It's funny but very honestly,
if we start talking about VR,
we're gonna make a lot
of assumptions right now
that are either gonna
play out or not play out
in 20 to 30 year window.
1996 internet was a whole
different fucking world,
and so I kept innovating.
Bought the word wine on
the day Google AdWords came out
for five cents a click,
that was a good bet.
(laughing)
And owned it for a long
time, and just did a lot
of smart digital
marketing things,
and then I did a
show on YouTube,
a couple months
after YouTube came out,
called Wine Library TV where
I sat in front of a camera
and drank four bottles
of wine for 20 minutes.
(laughing)
And a lot of people watched that
and that's how I hit the
scene in the tech world,
and then what happened
was YouTube sold
for $1.7 billion,
and I was like fuck,
I was right about e-com,
I was right about
Google AdWords,
I was right about cookie
retargeting banner ads,
I was right about YouTube.
Maybe this skill I have
for selling more
Burgundy and Priorat
can be deployed
against something
more financially interesting.
So when I read the article
about YouTube's sale,
there was one
article that featured
Ron Conway's angel investor,
investment,
and I said what the
fuck's an angel investor?
I googled it.
(laughing)
Within 20 minutes I decided
I would be an angel investor.
(laughing)
And went to South by
Southwest three months later,
became friends with
Ev Williams and Blaine Cook,
the original CTO,
and I think your firm at
the time, me and Kevin Rose,
bought up Blaine's
original stock of Twitter,
so I bought a ton of Twitter,
real cheap.
I didn't think of myself
as an angel investor,
I just thought that
was a smart decision
because I thought
Twitter would be big.
Then I went home f
rom South by, made a--
- [Ed] Profit, by the way?
- Well it did for me
because I sold my shares,
so I did good.
(laughing)
Came home, made a video,
I was making wine videos,
came home, made a
video that said
Facebook should be
worried about Twitter.
There was a guy who was head
of platform at the time,
at Facebook, that I didn't know,
by the name of
Dave Morin, sent me an e-mail
like, "Hey, this video
has gotten really viral
"inside of Facebook, would
you come out to Palo Alto
"and give a talk?"
So I came to room like this,
in front of the whole company,
it was only 400 employees,
and talked about
consumer behavior
and why I thought the
world was changing.
That caught Mark's attention,
we went out to
dinner that night,
and a week later I bought a
lot of stock from his parents,
and then somehow I got
David Karp to reopen
the B round of Tumblr,
by the way stick with me here,
the B round at a
$14 million valuation,
and I made an
investment into Tumblr.
So the first three things
I invested in were Twitter,
Facebook, and Tumblr.
(laughing)
Yeah, it was when I was smart,
I was making bets on things
that I thought would
be successful.
I didn't think of
myself as an investor.
I got progressively
stupider after that.
(laughing)
- [Ed] Why do you
think that was?
- Because I started
trying to be an investor.
I literally went from
being, I'm a businessman,
these are good businesses,
this is good.
The market changed.
I mean this is
Tumblr B round 2008.
B round 14 million.
Now every fake,
bullshit entrepreneur
running around this campus wants
seven million, four million
for their bullshit idea
that they have no prayer on,
because entrepreneurship
is popular,
and instead of going
to Bain or McKinsey,
they think they can
start a fucking app
that people are gonna use.
(laughing)
(clapping)
- [Ed] Those people
who are clapping,
are you clapping because
he just described you?
(laughing)
- Ed, they're always clapping
and laughing when I speak
because it's the truth,
we all know it.
This is the greatest era of
fake entrepreneurship ever,
which makes it challenging
for anybody here
that wants to go
into venture investing.
I barely created one
investment for myself last year
'cause I'm so scared of
the early stage ecosystem,
because the supply
and demand curve
of actual entrepreneurs that
can see these things through,
versus everyone who
fancies themselves in that,
has broke.
And so I'm just desperately,
I don't understand macro,
global economics well enough
to understand who and why this
is being held up for so long,
but I'm just desperately waiting
for this whole
fucking thing to crash.
(laughter)
- But here's the interesting
thing to me is that
at a certain point, you just
decided you were gonna be
an angel investor, you didn't
know what it was, right?
- That's right.
- So you just kinda like,
you just decided that's
what you were gonna be.
- I thought there was a moment
in time where the internet
that I grew up in, built
my dad's liquor store
was starting to hit true
scale and consumer behavior
was about to change for real.
And so things like
Birchbox and Uber
and other things I did well with
they were all still, back in
2007 to 2010-11 time frame
where valuations were a little
not more fair, but I would
tell you that we were all
I was very early stage,
we were still dealing
with four million dollar
idea stage, the difference is
the entrepreneurs that were
building those companies
in 2007, eight, nine,
10, they couldn't breathe
doing anything else.
There was no--
- They didn't think they were
going to get rich doing it.
- Some of them, I think some,
especially the early part.
My South-By 2007
experience was wild.
I went there.
I said something about business
and everybody looked at
me like I was the worst
piece of shit they'd ever seen.
This Web 2.0 movement
Growing from the ashes
of the first Web bubble,
these were people that wanted
to change the world for real.
I just wanted to sell
more Peter Michael Les Pavots.
That's for you.
- [Ed] That's a wine.
- That was for you.
So, yeah, that's true, but they
were also true entrepreneurs
every day, I meet, every
month I meet with 15 people
that 10 years ago, were
gonna be consultants
and bankers that now think
the Uber of dry cleaning
is their way out.
- But how do you evaluate
that? How do you evaluate
that person now, compared
to what you called
were the true believers?
- So, it really is interesting.
I've really gravitated
later and later stage
because I realized
my marketing talent
and what I was good at
over the last decade
is actually far better
used for things that have
a little maturity to them,
where I can use
my arbitrage of
marketing capabilities.
So, I've become less interested
in the very early stage
because the only thing I now
eval--, if I'm going to make
an angel investment pure
idea phase, I need to know
that that person's,
my 100% evaluation now
is on the person
could care less about the idea
and I need to know
if they sold Blow-Pops
in junior high.
Like, I'm not kidding, like.
- [Ed] When you say
Blow Pops, it doesn't matter
if they sold Blow Pops
as long as they started
some business.
- Zuck sold, like, like he
like put music on CD's
and sold them in cla--
Like, that's salesmanship DNA,
that grit,
that I can't breathe
without selling thing
is very needed because
the other problem we have
in the ecosystem and
we deal with this
is we also have a crazy
reaction to failure.
I've been at too
many dinners where
the dinner is,
I went out of business
and everybody sits around
the table in a circle jerk
of oh, it's great
that you learned.
(laughter)
- [Ed] And your view is
it sucks that you learned?
- My view is like, fuck,
I don't wanna lose my money.
And, like, I definitely
don't wanna buy you dinner
and make you feel
good that you suck.
(laughter)
But, but, right?
I mean we have an
unbelievably awesome culture
that has a unique twist to it.
Like, I don't know, like
it feels very weird that
I've worked very hard
my whole fucking life
wrote a $250,000 check.
The person was skiing,
skiing,
four months before his
company went outta business
and then I'm supposed
to go to a dinner
and celebrate the learnings
he had in three years?
That's broken.
That's the softness of
our current culture.
I genuinely believe that.
- [Ed] And do you think
that's your view because
does that relate back
to your upbringing?
- Sure.
I think it's a hell of
a lot easier to feel
the way I feel that,
because I walked K-Mart
when I was seven and split
toilet paper with my mom
versus going to fucking
Horace Mann in Columbia.
Yes.
- But Zuck didn't
grow up that way.
- Oh, by the way, I'm
talking 'bout me personally.
I don't think my
path is the only path.
I think there's
killers that went to
Horace Mann in Columbia.
But if you're asking
me the question
yes, I think that
my reaction to that--
- [Ed] By killers you mean
homicidal killers?
- Nah.
(laughter)
I mean the slang
term for real executors.
Here's what I know.
The balance of
this ecosystem, I don't
know what the class
wants to do, whether
build their companies
or go and invest.
as it currently sits right
now, it's never been tougher
at the earliest stage,
because you have just so
many pretenders, and
the truth is it's hard.
It's hard to like, figure them.
I can ask you about putting
music on CD's but like
that's only one
little tiny data point
You're really--
- But the number of
pretenders you have
is correlated with the rise
in the dollars available
to those pretenders--
- And the romance and branding
of being an entrepreneur.
The brand equity around
being an entrepreneur today
is stunning.
It is stunning for me
to, in the world like
I can't believe how cool it is
in real life to be an
entrepreneur.
And that makes a
lot of young individuals
gravitate towards that.
- But you're suggesting overall
that's worse than if
those young individuals
went to work for
Goldman Sachs or McKinsey
- I am, 'cause I'll
tell what we are not--
- You think the world
is a better place
even with the bad ideas?
- No, I do not.
- And getting funded by
- And let me explain why.
The biggest conversation
that I'm fascinated by
is the suicide rate
at Wharton last year.
So we have, in parallel
a narrative that
anybody can do it.
And everybody's entitled
to win in entrepreneurship.
And there's an
underbelly in our world
that I'm concerned about,
and you know we've talked
about this in a different panel
This is a big thing, I mean like
there's certain individuals
who've been winning
in the first
20 years of their life
in a game that was fixed
before they played it.
And then they go into the market
and the market
punches them in the mouth
and they don't know how to react
and so yes, I do think
for the cliched picture
that I'm painting right now
that there are certain
individuals that I just
genuinely believe would
have had a better life
being the number
seven at Facebook
instead of the
number one of Shitbook.
(laughter)
Or, or, or
making 230,000 a year
on Wall Street or Consulting
Land at 29 years old.
Yes, I think there's a lot of
people that would be better.
Like, I love
entrepreneurship the most
but nothing works when
it's forced or off-balance.
Nothing.
- [Ed] And Andy your
point is just like
do anything other than
Goldman's?
- Yeah, sort of, right,
in other words--
- Unless you're built
for Goldman--
- But what does
that mean, right?
- Well I know one thing.
Not everybody's built
to be an entrepreneur.
- No, that's right.
- That's insane.
- Right, but it works
the same way too, right.
In other words,
it used to be, right,
you graduate school and
then you go work for a bank
or a law firm or
you go into medicine.
Those were a
bunch of different paths.
- Which all suck if, for me.
- And they may, but some
people still do that, right?
- Yes.
- Entrepreneurship is
about being empowered
to take control of
your professional life.
- Okay.
- Right, at some level.
- Do you know how many
people are not capable of that?
Do you know how hard
entrepreneurship is?
- But that's the market though,
that's called the market.
It won't work for everyone.
Not everyone that goes
to work at McKinsey
or Goldman Sachs is
gonna be successful.
- That's like literally
telling a basketball player
that you should
become a hockey player.
You know that, right?
Like, like self-awareness
is very important.
And something that
should be debated.
And I think we're forcing
too many people into
the entrepreneurial
track that do not have
the stomach to be an
entrepreneur.
- When you say
we're forcing meaning
we are, or Ed is, or who is?
- All of us combined,
the ecosystem
the self-promotion within itself
the outside world
that decided it was
the cool thing to
talk about for a decade.
These pendulums swing.
But what I'm most worried
about, and I refer to it
'cause I believe that this
room all understand it
better than me
I'm dying to know
why it can still stay up.
Like there's so much
money in the system.
There's so much
other stuff going on and
government involvement and
so many other variables
that are playing out that
are just above my pay grade
that I'm fascinated
by when they cripple
because this much fakeness
has an inevitable fate.
- [Ed] So why
are you raising a fund?
- I'm raising a fund
because I'm going
Series B and Series C where
I think my marketing machine
that I've spent--so
my behavior, as you guys know
over the last five, six years
instead of where I had a lot
of leverage to raise capital
and do my thing
I took a major,
on paper, step back
and built a client service
digital social agency
that I've grown in
the last five years
from zero to
100 million in revenue
right?
To give me leverage for
when the shit hits the fan.
And so, what I want to do with
the fund in the short term
is deploy it against later
stage things that need
a marketing arbitrage
to create victory.
- [Ed] So,
you've basically said
I'm gonna make these wild
investments, I'll do it
in Series B because that's
where the funnel pinch
works for me.
- They'd feel a
lot less wild for me
coming from angel
A, so there's a lot more
data of an actual business
and B, I can look at it
and say, okay her business
she's got it all down
her one opening or
opportunity or soft spot is
marketing arbitrage
the way I do it
which I believe is best in class
that's a good bet for
me 'cause I can bring
the smartest money to the table.
- [Ed] And so, it's not just
that you've opened a barber shop
to get paid to do haircuts
in a downturn, so that
you don't lose all your venture
capital investible dollars,
it's that there's a symbiosis
between the barber shop and--
- Even further the reason
I am building VaynerMedia
right now is long term,
I think it plays out for me
on private equity
where I buy businesses
at scale and run them
through the machine
as I call the VaynerMedia
and make that arbitrage.
I took a step back seven
years ago and said,
you know what, now that I'm
hanging out with all these
fancy people, you
characters and way fancier
than you Travis, Sacca,
those kind of dudes,
I'm like I don't look like
these dudes and chicks,
I'm not these people,
like, here's what I am,
I'm a marketer and let me
quadruple down at that skill,
build infrastructure around that
and deploy it against
this world I believe in
so that's what I've
been focused on.
- [Ed] And where
does wine fit into this?
- So wine fits into it in
a couple of different ways.
I'll get very real and
transparent with you guys
and you know, you have such
a unique perspective on this.
My dad and I are
very different, you know,
like as different as you
can really get, you know,
personality-wise, viewing
the world, our backgrounds.
As I was building
Wine Library and I was getting
more attention and
things of that nature,
there was a real forming
tension for the first time
in our relationship
because, as you know,
my dad gave me
the greatest gift,
I walked in as a 22-year-old
and he gave me free reign.
I ran that business, every
decision, which is remarkable
in hindsight,
especially now that I'm 40
and he was 44 when he
allowed me to do that.
But as the narrative changes,
the business changed,
there was tension
between our relationship
on, you know,
him disappearing from
the narrative within
our industry that,
and at the same time
I made these good bets
and AJ, my brother was
graduating college,
just felt like the right
time to like make a decision
where I would hand it more
day to day back to him
and the management team I
built, Brandon and those guys.
So the real life answer
is for anybody that's been
in a family business, the
family business dynamic
created a scenario where,
because I had all these other
amazing options, there was
no reason to create friction
with one of the
two or three most
important relationships
in my life.
That's the real answer and
because I haven't been involved
day to day as much, I've
never enjoyed wine more
because I don't
look at a label anymore
and think profit
margin, you know,
which has been fun actually.
Ironically I'm probably
enjoying wine more than ever
and, you know,
in a different way,
the way that you look
at it because you have
such a passion for it,
I don't want to buy Dujac
or things of that nature,
but I think I might
make a run at
some point in creating
a three to $800,000,000
Yellow Tail like brand
just 'cause I think I can do it
and because I want to
buy the New York Jets.
(laughing)
I don't know that's just a--
- [Ed] That's a good
opportunity for us to see,
in the unlikely event that
any of you have questions
(laughing)
for these folks,
I'm happy to field them.
Do you want to start?
- [Clifton] Yeah, so with
this sort of inflating--
- What's your name?
- [Clifton] Clifton.
- Clifton.
- [Clifton] It's nice
to meet you.
- Nice to meet you, man.
- In this sort of inflated
ecosystem that you came in
as want to be entrepreneurs,
do you feel that it has
at least provided
more good innovation
that wouldn't have
existed otherwise?
- I don't know is
the real answer.
My intuition is probably
a little bit, yes,
but I genuinely believe
that great entrepreneurs
making great things, like
Travis was an entrepreneur
before Garret was an
entrepreneur,
like, I don't know.
I don't know, not as
much as some people
may want to think
because I think those
people would
have saw it through.
I think we grossly underestimate
hard wiring and talent.
I think we grossly, grossly
underestimate hard
wiring and talent.
I think those things
would have broke through
and would have happened anyway
and were happening
anyway, but probably,
I mean if you have more
people playing the game
that wouldn't have
played the game
and done something else, of
course there's going to be some
but I don't think as much upside
and I'm not sure
as much casualty
for the players in a
net-net offsetting game.
My opinion, what do you think?
- I think, this is where you
and I disagree a little bit--
- Yep.
- Although we agree
on some potential,
I think the karma in the world
is increased by more people
believing themselves
to be entrepreneurs,
whether they have the skills
to be successful or not,
I think the karma in
the world is increased,
you know, so,
so I think overall yes.
- I also think the internet,
itself, has created the
opportunity as much
as anything else.
The infrastructure costs to
be in the game are so low
that's as much of a thing,
I don't think anybody
became more talented
or capable or visionary
because the internet came along.
I think it just
exposed the opportunity--
- but what's interesting--
- At a greater level.
- Here's what's interesting,
at the same time
that also made it
much more difficult
for any individual to succeed
because everyone can do it.
- I totally agree.
- Right.
- It makes it
definitely more difficult--
- But, but--
- to be investors, too.
- For sure.
- Right?
- I agree, but the cost
of starting is so low--
- It's zero.
- So low, you just say it,
you're an entrepreneur.
Mazel Tov.
(laughing)
- [Ed] So, so--
- I'm so used to doing
Q and A, I'm like ...
What?
- [Ed] What are the
ramifications--
- You're asking your own guy.
- [Ed] We know
we're on your show.
What are the
ramifications of this fallout
for all of the venture
funds because there are some
interesting structural
ramifications to
what your saying. Right?
Because obviously and
I do agree that there
is definitely more garbage in
and there definitely, you know,
used to be that,
like, it was nerdy,
it was geeky and
people would ignore you
they would want to go talk to
the people who run hedge funds.
- Yep.
- [Ed] And that's great,
and that was actually
a much more
comfortable place to be
for a whole bunch of
reasons but structurally
we're going to be screwed
if we have a whole wave
of venture funds
investing in companies
that never should have attracted
investment capital--
- That's what's
going to happen.
- [Ed] And behind them
a whole bunch of LP's
managing pension
funds and endowments
that lose their money
by investing in these
misguided and venture funds--
- Except that, except that
the software internet
based technology
as an asset
cost is pretty small.
So the damage, right, if 50%
of all venture investments,
investments in the venture
funds this year went bust
it's 15 billion dollars,
it's not that big.
- It's just big for the
human individuals.
- [Ed] That's real money.
- No, no, no,
it's not big for like
macroeconomics.
- Yeah.
- There's no
- Yeah, that's true.
- The first bubble we
shifted the risk to
the public.
- [Ed] Yeah.
- That's more meaningful.
Now we've contained the risk
to institutional investors.
When we raised our last fund
this year, earlier in the year,
when we were out
talking to our investors,
we told them that we believe
for the next ten years
venture returns on average
will be lower than they were
the ten years before and
they should expect the return
from our fund and all
the funds they invest in
to be somewhere between
20% and 50% lower.
- That's called sandbagging.
- Yes.
(laughing)
But also believe in that.
- Yeah, so--
- You look at the data
the data suggests--
- So are you
also raising money for Union
Square ventured short fund?
(laughing)
- No, but our last two
investments have
been in hedge funds though.
- Yes, go ahead.
- [Woman] So you
talked a little bit
about inflated entrepreneurship
but you could argue
there's also right now
inflated investors, like--
(Gary blows raspberry)
- You are damn right, sister.
(laughing)
They work hand in hand.
- [Woman] Right, so the
question is, who should then,
you talked about who
should be an entrepreneur,
who should be an investor?
- You know, I don't get
to judge who should.
I'm just excited to
see how it plays out.
(laughing)
Do you know what I mean?
I mean who should?
Who should do
anything in the world?
The people, you know,
what I love about this is
there'll be plenty of
winners during this era,
there'll just be
a lot more losers.
You know and so that's all.
It's just a timing thing.
This is so classic.
This is every market on
everything always and forever.
It's why I love brands so much.
This is when brand
takes over reality.
(loud slamming)
(laughing)
I know that was a big statement.
So I think a lot of,
like I grew out of,
my crew grew out of
the angel, super angel,
guys and gals that were
successful in their
first internet business,
made some money,
and had enough
Twitter followers,
let's get to the punch line to
attract unbelievable deal flow.
I made a lot.
I'm going to continue
to make a lot of money
from that pocket,
but a lot of us
shouldn't necessarily
be investors.
We maybe should keeping
some investment behavior
but we should all
really map ourselves,
but yeah, I think it's,
I think all of this comes down
to the supply and
demand of the skills.
I just think people are
very attracted to this world
and I think if you,
especially when I sit
in a class like this,
you know, I try to
reverse engineer
every situation I'm in,
especially how do I bring value?
If I could get one
person in this room to
actually pay attention tonight,
go home, look in the mirror,
and try to start deploying
aggressive self-awareness,
it could change the
upside of their lives.
I genuinely believe that.
I just,--
- As long as they don't
work for Goldman and Sachs.
- Or they should, I mean,
or maybe they should
work for their family business.
I don't know but I know that
way too many people
just go with the flow.
I know how strong minded
I am and how easy that is
for me to get caught
up and so I just think
it's a worthwhile
conversation, especially 'cause
too many people make
a decision on the now,
not on when they're
actually playing it out.
Doesn't really matter to you
if you do in this world today,
it matters what the impact is
over a 36 to 60 month window
and that you have
to really quantify that.
Looking at data told
you what happened.
You need to deploy
real intuition
and other kind of signs
to what's going to happen
so you can make
the decision for you.
- You have a question?
- [Man] So I guess this question
is supposed to be around
internet tech entrepreneurship.
So, you guys see this
kind of hype going on,
craziness going on, but
outside this industry,
do you see any other
industry that was like
internet, many, many years ago,
started booming
in it's early days,
but has very great potential?
- I mean, real estate
does this all the time.
Real estate gets hot
and then gets real cold when
the C players show up.
And I'm sure historically
every market has
gone through this.
It's the same old narrative.
It's really rinse and repeat.
You can deploy the same
thesis on this over and over.
There's something that's right.
Early visionaries
take advantage of it,
get disproportionate
returns on it.
Everybody hears about it.
The next fast followers move in,
do sometimes alright.
And then the worst part happens,
everybody shows up.
- So it's interesting because
you're concerned with the
personal cost...
- I am.
- Of that last part.
- Because,
nobody here really gives a
fuck about macroeconomics.
- No, I understand that, right.
- They care about their lives.
- Right.
- So that's what
I'm deploying here,
if this was the
macroeconomics summit,
maybe I would talk a
little bit about that.
- Yeah but, I think you
can combine them right?
- I think so.
- Because history tells us that
bubbles actually may
not be a bad thing.
- I agree.
- They may be
a good thing, right?
A way to figure out the
proper allocation of capital.
- You mean when people...
I totally agree.
- Right?
- That's the best part
of the market, right?
I really want death...
- Right.
- Right now, like I want
shit to get carnage,
because that's a good, you know?
Because then you
get rid of D players.
- Right, right, and you start
that whole cycle over again.
- Yeah, I mean people
go to these events and
parties...
Go ahead.
(laughter)
I mean, it's an ecosystem,
it's a broken ecosystem.
People drinking
expensive wine at parties,
at fucking... in Aspen.
It's just like...
- My parties.
- My parties too,
I mean it's an ecosystem.
- So, but I think
the question was
what's the specific industry
that you would encourage him
to go out and attack, right now.
- I don't know.
- What he means is,
he knows and fuck if
he's gonna tell you.
(laughter)
- I don't know
and it's timing right?
The only thing on the horizon
of arbing the internet world
is the VR world, but is
that 30 years from now?
So many of our friends are
gonna lose a ton of money on
consumer VR, because they want
it to be here in 24 months.
It's not here in 24 months.
And so, there's
things that are,
the smart-ification of products,
AR, that's real.
That's voice space with
Alexa and things like that.
There's gonna be places to play,
there's micro-trends
within our world.
I don't know
things outside of tech,
you know?
I just don't know.
Or consumer,
direct to consumer brands
is gonna happen
over the next 20 years.
Your toothpaste is
coming to your house.
The channel conflicts
between retail and CPG.
Very real.
They'll be money to be made.
So, there's stuff.
But do you have the timing down?
Do you know
which jockey to bet on?
- [Man 2] So,
you talked about
printing and pressing CDs
in drive and you know,
having brought a sales
process or whatever that may be.
Are there certain triggers,
you know,
tangible or intangible,
either of you look
for in a founder
to signal that it's not
one of these crap companies
that you're alluding to?
- I met a founder yesterday
and he's going blind.
And for the past three
years he's been building
voice applications
for himself.
Because he can't
see a screen anymore.
- Scratching your own itch.
- Right? And it may
be a good business
and it may not, doesn't matter.
But, for me it's like,
are you trying to solve a
problem that you experience?
Are you trying to solve
something that
bothered you?
And this is an extreme example.
This is a guy that
can't see a web page,
can't see his phone.
But there are lots of
other flavors of that.
- I would say mine, less in
theory and more in practicality.
There's only two
things that I've...
Like right now I'm not investing
in first time entrepreneurs
that have had
zero success ever before.
Let me remind you,
most of the biggest
wins in our space
came from those kind of people.
So I don't think that's right,
it's just what I'm
comfortable with right now.
I want to see a body of
work, of doing it before.
You don't need
a big exit, but I wanna
see how you rolled,
because I think the thing...
Some of the best companies
I've invested in,
in my last fund,
the entrepreneur is dealing
with the people issue.
It's the people issue.
They're the right
product guy or gal.
They have the right vision.
They've got a lot
of things in place.
They're a great engineer.
They don't know
how to manage people,
or the people issue, so.
But I'm a huge fan, when I
think of my ecosystem of people.
When I really poke
and prod of the
entrepreneurs that have
graced the cover of
business magazines from our
world over the last half decade,
I know so many of them.
God, a stunning
amount of them sold shit.
And I like it.
And I associate with it.
And that's it,
it's important to me,
because it shows
a desire to sell stuff,
and that's part
of building a business
and very black and white.
But there's obviously a lot
of backgrounds that people
come from and win.
But those are the two
things I'm looking at.
- So are you only investing
in people who've actually
already made some money?
- Not made money, but
something that I can look at
and understand.
Not, I have an idea and
I think this is cool.
- So we're a bit
of the opposite,
we believe in
the drive of the person
that has never done it and that
wants to succeed so badly.
- So fucking cool.
- It's just different
strategies.
- No it's cool because,
the truth is,
it just reminds
everybody in this room,
there's no right answer.
- Right.
- But I do think there's
a right answer for you.
And I think that's something
to really focus on.
Not because it worked for
that person you admire,
but because that's where
your strength lies.
- Go ahead.
- [Woman 2] When you
meet with an entrepreneur,
or a potentially big
entrepreneur
and decide not
to invest in them,
or their company, how candid
are you with that person,
those people and how do
you balance that with
exactly what you
guys have talked about,
about trying to help
people find their way,
or be frank with
each other or get the
shit out of the system?
- I'm not super candid.
I hate confrontation,
believe it or not.
(laughter)
And it's a weakness of mine.
I'd rather not deal
with the negative vibes,
and so, I do a really
terrible, poor, non-noble job
in my rejections of investments.
- [Woman 2] Is
that also, in part, because
you want to keep the
door open should they...
- Possibly, maybe.
- [Woman 2] ...keep
the door open should they...
- It's more predicated,
for me personally it's
more predicated on just
my general dislike for
negativity and confrontation
if I don't have to deal with it.
- You feel like you just
don't want to be disliked?
- Yeah.
- Is that why you
agreed to come here?
- Yeah.
(laughter)
- We appreciate that.
- No worries.
I mean I think if,
you know, time.
You know, Phil can tell
them we're passing.
That's just good for me.
It's faster
and I didn't have to
feel the bad feelings,
I don't know, that's my truth.
I'm sure they do it way
more professionally.
- (Laughing) I don't know if
it's a better way to do it.
We deal with...
I think as an investor,
you deal with uncertainty
and so you're telling someone
you're not interested in
their company is
your perspective.
You know, you could be wrong.
A lot of times we've been wrong.
We were wrong about Uber.
We were wrong about airBnB.
- It's just part of the game.
- Yeah, so who knows.
- I was super
wrong about Yobongo.
- What?
- Yobongo.
I was obsessed.
In thesis I was right.
I was obsessed with
the fact that Grindr
was gonna become
a male-female thing.
Which it did.
Tinder and all that.
So I was chasing that space.
There was a
company called Yobongo,
that I invested in, in 2008.
Which was people discovery.
Highlight.
One.
I just kept chasing all of
them and of course it was
incubated inside of IAC,
the one that won, but
I just was convinced that that
was gonna be a huge winner.
- Why was that a category
that you felt good about
investing in the first place?
- All my money, in my whole
life, will be predicated on
understanding people's behaviors
slightly ahead of the market.
That's where I win.
I just was a 100% positive
that people would date.
Male and female dynamics would
translate the same way that
male and male
dynamics played on Grindr.
I just was a whole
pot committed.
Like I was with social.
Like I am with
VR, long term.
And then you just, then
it's a timing game.
- Go ahead.
- [Man 4] So I'm curious,
for some of the
business school students,
that may not think of
themselves as founders,
but do want to work for
portfolio companies in
a functional role that
fits their skill set.
What's your thought
around that, where
maybe in some way, we're
motivated by the equity that
entrepreneurs might be...
- Yeah.
- [Man 4] focused on,
but it is the
right role and it
can be a good
trajectory as well.
- Yeah again,
I'm so not interested in
my point of view carrying
all that much weight,
but that being said, yeah
I think that's really right.
Whatever it is that
is most self-aware,
if you've got that, roll with
that all the way through.
Not what mommy and
daddy or Fast Company
or Zucks told you.
Yeah, I mean
I think that's great.
And I would tell
you another thing.
We've never lived in an era
where you can get to
that person so easily.
It's just relentless attack.
Twitter and LinkedIn
and email and...
You can get to that per...
It's unbelievable who you
can get to, if you just try.
- What's the best
way to get to you?
- Twitter.
I still look at every mention.
Believe it or not, Twitter
is still the best way.
- You have like a million,
some odd followers.
- Yeah, but I still
look at those mentions.
It's data collection for me.
It's how I make a lot of my
decisions and so of course
I'm gonna see the person...
You know, I'm gonna see it,
doesn't mean I'll, you know.
- Yeah.
Are there more questions?
Go ahead.
- [Man 5] So back to the
investment side,
I believe a lot of
people in this room
are interested in pursuing
a VC career right out of school
like a junior investment
professional.
What do you guys
think about this idea?
Do you think there's a lot
of fakeness there as well?
(laughter)
- I don't know what fakeness is.
Gary can talk about
what fakeness is,
but here's what I think.
I think that one of the
things that's interesting
about being in a venture,
if you think about,
you've got two parties and
there's a power relationship,
right, and there's
a perception that
the investor has a lot of power,
so your ego is satisfied
by being that investor,
but at the same
time the reality is
for the good businesses
that get entrepreneurs
that's actually not
the way it is, right,
it's flipped around
the other side,
and so I don't, it took me,
I had to start my company
and raise money
'til I realized that
and I was 20 years
into my career
'til that insight, which
helps me invest now,
'til I realized it, I don't
know how you would learn it.
The problem with venture is that
you don't get paid for 10 years.
You have to be willing to
not get paid for a decade.
Well, I mean, okay, but you
get paid a lot of base salary.
- You also invest
an enormous amount--
- Yes, but Ed's right,
you know how many people
have venture firms just for
the fuckin' management fees?
Like, that's just real.
Like, there's a lot of
people that were able to
off their personal
brand in this era,
build $25-150 million
venture funds
and make a real
fucking awesome living
just on that two percent
because they're
thinking so short term.
That's real, that's a real
thing, it's a nice living
compared to other things.
- I don't know that those things
are so short term, though,
because there're also thinking
like why am I not going
to do a great job at this?
- Yes, I think others are, like,
'cause we've all been there
at three o'clock in the
morning, like, hey listen,
the booby prize is
a great fuckin' salary
to have a great
fuckin' lifestyle.
I mean, that's just real.
That's not the market,
but that is the growing,
there is a subset growing market
of what I just described,
and the other thing is
I genuinely believe that
this class doesn't have
this many people in
it seven years ago.
- It didn't.
- Right, so--
(laughter)
Well, seven years
ago was after '08.
Before '08 they
were all going to
Goldman and McKinsey and Bain
and it was like
a third of the size.
- The far majority of
this room, not everybody,
but there's an enormous amount
of majority of this room
that follows a certain track
that makes this class
have more people in it,
and that supply and demand
issue is the problem.
- It is, but at the same time--
- I believe,
one man's point of view.
- I think there's a counter.
The counter is, you had this
up on your screen before,
10 years ago,
if you're a venture firm
and you're raising money,
your slide #2 talked about
this thing called
proprietary deal flow,
which was the
way you got deals--
that no one else
could see. Right?
But here's the thing, they're
all just internet businesses,
so there's nothing proprietary.
You all can subscribe
to App Annie
and look at the
app charts all day long--
- Every day.
- I have no advantage over
anyone in this room, right?
- No, that's not true.
- No, yes it is.
- It's not true.
- Sure it is, no, no,
no, you're right.
Of course you have
an advantage over him.
- No, but if I--
(laughter)
- You have personal brand
equity and firm equity.
- But the entry point.
- Yeah, the entry point's zero.
- No, the entry
point's the same.
- Correct.
- It used to be
only I saw it, right?
- Yes, that game is over.
- That game is over, right?
- Yes.
- So the entry point--
- Which is why
brand matters more now.
- Right, but
I may have reputation,
I have a fund that has capital
that will do follow on investments--
- Charisma.
- But the (laughter) but the
en, you're running out of time,
but the entry point, the
entry point is the same.
You may have an insight--
- You get the data--
- You had an insight that
selling wine about social media,
that was the
line for you, right?
So someone else could
replicate that a different way.
Someone else could find
that somewhere today
on Twitter, on Facebook, right?
So the entry point's the same.
That means we have to do better,
we have to hold our brand--
- Or it speaks to why
the game we're playing
is actually broken.
If everybody's looking
at the same data,
you all end up in the same place
when the opportunity's
somewhere completely else.
- That's separate, though.
- And very important.
- Yes, so to answer
your question,
that's the market to look at.
- Agreed.
- The someplace else market?
- Yeah.
- Yep, oh by the way, by
the way, always, right?
- Tulip bowl.
- Always, though.
There's somebody who had a
hand over there, I saw, yeah.
- [Man 6] I got a
question on that.
So, you came from
Betaworks and now
those guys Nick and whatnot
spun that off in (mumbles).
You seem (mumbles)
Brooklyn, Grand Central,
and a lot of those bigger
ones in the middle.
Is there this hybrid space
developing where you are,
you do have an
investment vehicle,
but you're also
committed to the companies
and to the people
involved with you there,
day in and day out.
Is there more interest
and integrity with that?
- I don't know if there's
more interesting integrity.
The thing that happened, you
know, capital used to be scarce
and capital isn't scarce.
Attention is the last
remaining asset that's scarce,
and so, if that's
the last remaining--
- What's the last remaining?
- Attention.
- Attention, giving someone's
attention
and getting someone's attention,
so if that's it, right, the
advantage that I may have
as an investor is how
I manage my attention
and how I manage the attention
of someone who wants my money
or someone I've invested
in, not the capital itself,
so those things are
kind of interesting.
Like no one cares
more about his companies
than Charlie Adom.
He may be a good investor,
he may not, but
no one spends
more time with them.
- There's a different
between the founder,
and this goes back to
the case we did today,
there's a difference between
being a founder-led company
and saying, I have a
really good idea,
let's go hire some young
person and give them
eight percent of the
company to go,
they'll stay here
and even though they can
make a lot of the decisions,
they can't make all
of the decisions--
- I get it.
- And I am big brother
watching, and it's my money,
and I'm spending up from LPs
to make this shit all happen.
And they get to move out of
my space when I tell them,
and they get to hire this person
if I tell them that's okay.
They're walking around
with a card that says CEO--
- I get it.
- But they're not
really the CEO,
and it depends on
some of those spaces,
but I've seen that model a lot,
and you won't
invest in a company
where the CEO
isn't really the CEO
and doesn't have enough
equity in the business
to make it matter,
because that person took a job,
that person is not a
founder, he took a job.
- I understand,
I'll tell you the reason
I really try hard, is
because I care more about
my legacy and reputation than
anything else in the world.
- And that's a great
place to end, thank you,
thank you very much.
(applause)